we're realizing here today I have
siblings manaman siblings will they come
to see you on the Dancing with the Stars
tour I don't know my home and dad that
everybody knows all right Hannah and
Alan we're here rehearsals with our
dancing with the stars' champs we don't
even have to rehearse anymore new
champions of Dancing with the Stars
[Applause]
I mean does it still feel good to say
you want we talked about Hansen really I
can't believe I'm still here I can't
believe it I hate when he says back but
I also it is surreal because I'm like
I'm pretty good if you did amazing but
it's feeling but it is everybody was so
good so it's it is an honor but also
feels really awesome
it's nice to reflect on it afterwards
like oh that week was really difficult
but we made it where are you guys as
mental states at right now because the
competition is so crazy then you win now
you're a couple weeks out do you look
back and think I can't believe I won do
you look back and think oh my gosh I
finally have been able to breathe a
little bit how are you
breathe oh my I'm barely breathing yes
your little sec yeah but I think I just
feel a sense of gratitude I mean when
you're in the process it can be so
frustrating and so stressful when you're
like but you just get so focused on the
day-to-day and not thinking of the
overall and now it's like wow I cannot
believe I did that that we accomplished
so much not even just winning but just
every single week every week we did and
so yeah I think gratitude and just
having the fans that allowed us yeah and
it's just been really amazing and I'm
just super thankful I have to tell you
like just talking you a little bit you
seem a little lighter like I either need
you advocate the Stars was going and I
knew that's so stressful but you seem a
little like lighter happier like are you
past distressing I'm I was I was
stressed all the time and I can't even
blame her I was stressing I feel like
she was absorbing my stress that's true
you had a couple breakdown moments
oh absolutely everyday probably at least
one minor one but I just cared so much
and I knew I could and in wanted to
succeed not just like by winning but
just feel like every time I did my very
best and I would just put so much
pressure on myself and I'm glad that the
pressure paid off but yeah it feels
really good to be able to just relish in
the win and know that it was all worth
it looking back are there any moments
where you think
I wish I'd been a little more chill in
that moment or two both yes we were
talking we're so similar that like we'll
at least I'll speak for myself I get
really like obsessed about one little
thing or like go crazy I'm better than
after I was it yeah we let's just hug it
out we're fine and then sometimes you've
got nuts do it again sometimes you think
give me a hug I'm like nope not until
you do it and there are times I would be
like I would like you know have one of
my crazy hand amendments and then
obviously that was a little crazy I
think that's it that's what helped us
though we realized that we were both the
same in both a little what moment comes
to mind for you and you look back for me
I know about you okay I'll tell the one
about you and you tell the one about me
would be so many so many I think we
should tell him okay let me see what
you're saying you know the one I'm gonna
say the craziest moment um we were I
think I oh I had gotten to dance you
know I'm so good it was American girl
quick step I are you know and like a
two-hour break and I came back to our we
took a 20-minute break to look at
contemporary songs okay
and then I I'm just dead pretty bad he
was like what the crap he literally was
like oh god we have to shoot the wide
what's happened I was like yeah I was
like walking around like what just
happened we don't remember any so like
try the pose here out basically and that
dramatic you guys just calling each
other crazy now you tell me which one um
there's a lot because honestly hmm there
was one I'll say the one in the finale
about pit bull so we were already
running away it like we're to get on
stage we just came back from the
wardrobe fitting the finale is hectic
and we had to do like four eighths in
the pit bull number where all the
finalists walk out and Val and Jenna
Claire got that one and handles like
water my steps I was like I don't know
just go and she comes thing you didn't
teach me my steps housing I don't know
the steps it was a little bit probably
more dramatic
- I know what here you are yo you want
it you're together where the Mirrorball
you where is the Mirrorball you guys
love that Mirabeau mines under my tree
right now i don't know why my mom put it
there happy holidays she was like all
these presents and then just she just
randomly put the trophy under there I
think just to be cuz you each get one
yes yes but you know we still Dina it's
ringing in the New Year for you maybe
that's it
yeah well I have only like a little bit
of furniture at my place right now so
there's really no where else to put it
right now so it's under the tree but I
have a Christmas tree okay might not
have any other furniture but I have a
Christmas tree and you kind of made
yours your child if you just the
Mirrorball someone named it for us my
name's Rumble and hers is named tango
yeah it's a fan this is your baby and
this is one of the only things you even
have in Europe yeah so you guys are
doing a big stop Radio City Music Hall
yeah does that feel pretty amazing that
you're performing there my mom and this
is like her dream come true for me
they're you they're actually coming to
New York to watch me but that is such an
iconic place and that I I don't know how
I'm able to dance I'm a I'm super
thankful that I am getting to perform at
Radio City and I don't know what I'm
saying amazing but I have to say it was
the fans they they might really get one
stop why only one stop you know my life
has drastically changed so I'm just
trying to sort out what time I have when
I'm busy when I'm not what's what's
coming up in this next year so we'll see
but I'm really excited about Radio City
I think it's gonna be a good time I'm
gonna be huge how is the Beast gonna
come out as you prepare for this big
show we're doing one of the ones that
definitely these came out yeah it's
gonna be fine okay yeah I love it and I
know you know tours are happening
ping-pongs happening pranks are
happening dude will you guys be playing
any pranks on anybody or each other
I hope not on each other
you know I was with Chris Harrison
literally an hour ago and he said that
your appearance on Petes season he said
it's big I'm just so confused now what
are you doing here making decisions for
my heart because I know there's still
something there and I would do anything
for a relationship he said there are
still things there he said things happen
what can we expect I don't know what
does he mean about this Hannah I don't
know I guess we'll have to see what is
it January 6 look at that a helpful plug
for ABC Thank You Hannah a good sort of
ABC I also got ask you the women were
revealed today oh we don't even know a
lot of pageant women well okay here's my
Mathew Chris literally said we're kind
of continuing the package out that I do
mine like what's up with that I don't
know they thought it worked with Hannah
we got the Hannah Kailyn thing we got
Hannah G like they're just continuing
this pageant thing and we'll see how it
works out
do you is there any way you know any
other pageant girls
when I'm not to say an extremely crazy
what would you say if I asked you to
come be part of that house I feel like
the pageant road is small so you like of
people sometimes says okay maybe well do
you think there's a chance Peter ends up
with a pageant woman there's also girls
from Alabama aren't there like aren't
they all pageant girls that probably
says I'm sorry and some Alabama women I
was like okay maybe pelopidas a type I
don't know I don't know we definitely
have one pageant alum Alabama woman but
as you and I talked about you're like I
least fooling Dancing with the Stars
yeah so we'll see how much you're on
yeah but I also feel like with you if
you're on for a little bit you make a
big impression
all right so any must-haves for your
tour like at this point are you guys
like okay we have a ritual before we go
out on stage together or like we got to
touch our mirror ball for good luck or I
got to have an mm I don't know what are
your go-to I know yeah I haven't done it
I feel like our most renowned go-to is
our yellow yeah so yeah definitely have
can you do it for us she lost her voice
but three two one yeah we're back we're
back on the tour
how will you guys be heading out onto
that big stage a little nervous or do
you just know it but it's gonna be
really fun yeah I think there's no
pressure it's just exciting and it's
it's a celebration on stage
[Music]